c'est une image qui a fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux ce week-end celle de ce
jeune homme interpellé par trois
policiers dans sa chambre d'hôtel à
paris le 16 février dernier
mais ce n'est pas l'interpellation en
elle même qui a fait polémique mais des
propos d'un des policiers violents qui
insinue qu'en banlieue les règles
seraient différentes et que les forces
de l'ordre agiraient pas de la même
manière
une vidéo qui relance encore un peu plus
le débat sur la place de la police dans
les banlieues ce soir donovan le frère
de l'interpeller auteurs de la vidéo est
avec nous pour nous dire ce qu'il s'est
réellement passé
merci à donovan d'être là merci beaucoup
donovan donc on a vu on va voir la vidéo
qui fait polémique 1 et comptabilise
près de 700000 vu près des besoins de
niro tweets
regardez c'est pas regarder la vidéo
[Musique]
mais tard masques alors cette scène tout
le monde en a parlé c'est vrai que ça a
beaucoup pesé
donovan la scène est très chaud comme ça
s'est passé ou cette scène à paris dans
un grand hôtel un hôtel ont malgré cela
un hôtel dont paris paris mène paris
mais moins donc là pourquoi vous étiez
dans cet hôtel en fait passer du temps
en famille c'est ça passer du temps en
famille d habiter où normalement paris
paris d'accord et vous êtes diaw a
réservé un hôtel c'était quoi c'était
pour faire un voile à savoir un temps
que s'étaient pas vus d'accord je vais
faire pour qu'on soit d'accord alors
tout s'est bien passé la première vue
tout s'est bien passé la première nuit
ou se passe bien lors de la deuxième
demie le responsable exige à votre frère
qui prennent une nouvelle chambre pour
ses enfants de 6 et 5 ans dans le
suivant coop cinq ans alors j'ai pas les
bons usages
ils ont six et cinq ans et c'est normal
est annoncé pour moi c'est clair donc
votre frère refuse pour de prendre cette
problème chambre se fait hélas il alors
l'hôtel appelle les forces de l'ordre on
ya vu c'était un petit peu tendu avec
entre l'hôtel et votre frère ou pas du
tout on va dire sans il y avait un
désaccord et la corde accor hôtels
ne voulait pas qu'on reste larkham
d'accord voulait pas qu'on reste là si
on n'avait pas pris une troisième
chambre de plus mais on met neveu
d'accord alors et mon frère il a dit non
voilà d'où c'est sûr ça vous aide à l
appeler la police
la plus élévée venus ils ont dit non on
gère pas ce genre de sa création cette
affaire c'est n'est pas là pour gérer
des trucs comme ça
et quand vous avez vu dans la vidéo
parmi les trois policiers un cas voulu
faire un look aux boys et voilà je les
remarques de la fossella la phrase kiev
qui a fait polémique
vous avez vu tout cette vidéo ce ce week
end forcément
comment a réagi votre frère ensuite ça
s'est calmé ça s'est il avait pris une
troisième chambre vous avez quitté
l'hôtel et c'est quoi on m'a pris une
chambre en fait pour l amener s'est
retrouvé à un terrain d'entente ont déjà
pris une chambre en dehors pour moi
d'accord pour trouver un terrain
d'entente
parce que la dame de noter les maladies
carrément que ce qu'elle soit femme ou
son chevalet d'or
donc vous avez des traits c'est comme à
l'hôtel soit votre frère il reste à
l'hôtel avait un la femme et ses enfants
et moi il m'a pris notre chambre
votre frère il restait calme il est ou
bien il ya une très calme tendu avec les
policiers à gaza qu'il a prononcée
classe gruissan ont reçu en fait le
problème c'est sa sécu tellement qu'il
était calme
feinberg le policier l'accord dit et
quand même eu la boule et là parler
posément sans insulte rien du tout et le
policier chez pai en plus le plus face
vrai qu'il est énervé déjà d'éclat les
minimes et nerveux avant de parler avec
mon frère c'est vrai que c'est une
petite a fait en plus avec eux mêmes
l'hôtel déroger la police pour ça ils
ont pas un système et ils sont pas une
cellule mais parce qu'il s'est rien
passé pour que les gens de l'hôtel
appelle la police et ça parce que c'est
ça semble assez gratuite contient
différend commercial on ne met pas la
police générale la première lui c'est
très bien très bien donc à pas des pulls
et ses deux enfants en bas âge seul dans
une chambre c'est pas très intelligent
de sa part monterait à la la c'est la
nounou
c'est super sympa mais deux gamins de
raison et c'est dans une chambre d'hôtel
merci mon super semaine sur le jus sur
la forme quand même méfiance que là on
est en train de juger une affaire sur
une vidéo qui dure quelques d'accord on
sait pas très bien qui parle je remet
pas du tout en cause votre honnêteté je
dis juste que voilà une vidéo de
quelques secondes avec tout le monde m'a
ce qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dire
n'importe quoi à n'importe qui après si
c'est avéré que ces policiers ont
prononcé cette phrase c'est honteux
c'est scandaleux et c'est ce genre de
dérapages qui contribue à donner une
très mauvaise image de la police en
france malheureusement oui
non moi la question j'ouvre ces jeux
qu'on brade pourquoi la police est venue
dans l'hôtel
en fait vous êtes bien vous êtes 4-5-6
vous êtes combien en frais et avec sa
femme
ouais mais deux neveux des entraîneurs
donc ses deux jambes puisque normalement
ces deux par chambre
enfin il a pris une suite été imprécis
d'accord une suite mais pour moi le
favori bien dans votre chambre celle je
comprends pas est ce que le presque
plein fouet le thème général de l'hôtel
et on sait que chaque fois qu'un hôtel
se plaint le policier vient de frapper
aux journées justement nous ont dit les
policiers les légendes l'hôtel pourra
justifier l'appel à la police
qu'est ce qui vous en dit ils ont dit
qu'on reçoit en prêt une chambre de plus
sous son nez dehors oui gilbert
incroyable mais vrai ce que dit la
famille de daul en vannes c'est que la
responsable de l'hôtel a voulu abuser
ses terres faire payer une chambre
supplémentaire d'accord et ce qui est
très étonnant c'est que la police est
venu trois fois la famille mais fait
qu'un possible ou trois fois et c'est la
première fois où il ya cette phrase
ce qui est étonnant aussi c'est que moi
je voulais dire c'est que vous ayez
garder la vidéo pendant un mois
mais aujourd'hui sortie ou un bon après
y'a plein de gens qui demandent sa sur
les réseaux mais j'ai eu peur de
balancer au début d'accord la vidéo j'ai
eu peur mais en fait le qui m'a fait le
déclic mais que je balance la vidéo
c'est quand mes neveux ils ont ils ont
eu peur que leur père y sort dort bien
servi d'appât pas j'ai peur que les
coupent la tête parce qu'ils ont entendu
tout ce qu'ils sont
tout ce qui s'est passé tout ce qui
s'est dit vous voulez porter plainte
pour ce qui s'est passé ou pas du tout
on va porter pâle ah oui vous savez
comme ça dans un état de droit et que il
ya des institutions républicaines qui
sont là pour juger ce genre d'affaires
notamment l'igpn vous avez pas eu le
réflexe envoyé ces images directement
les gipn j ai loi en cas de problème
saisi le parquet et la justice tombe
conduit vas-y mulhouse
à limoux je sais que bon ben voila je
sais que ta ta ta beaucoup bouclier tout
ça mais radio ici quoi le premier jour
pas si maurice teulier voilà est ok il
te demandais comment ça s'est fini sur
toi comment ça s'est unie à leurs maux
ben comme jésus on a trouvé un terrain
d'entente d'accord avec les hôtels et
les doubles une chambre d'or une chambre
pour moi d'or un autre hôtel le total et
son frère est resté d'hôtel dargaud
l'hôtel et on va suivre la faire
d'accord vous veniez nous voir pour dire
nous dire comment ça se passe d'accord